[Music]  [Applause]  99 Street Elementary and south-central  Los Angeles which is part of partnership  for Los Angeles schools this is a  non-profit doing some amazing things for  LA kids so thank you so much for being  here y'all it sounded amazing  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  one two one two  [Applause]  Oh  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  what part these things primal do you  think out so Cinna  yeah I don't know you sound amazing well  thank you for thank you thank you for  coming I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this